[Inaudible].
The South Korean film parasite made a clean sweep at the 2020. Yeah.
First time in history, a non-English language film won the main award,
the Oscar for best film and addition to three other awards.
So if this were not visual politic,
we may be mistaken for believing that South Korea is at the top of their game
lately. However, you know that here on visual politics,
we like to go a little bit deeper.
And.
The truth is that the South Korean economy is going through a bit of a rough
patch both now. And even before the coronavirus pandemic in a positive video,
we told you how the South Korean model seems to be exhausted in today's video.
We're going to talk about another one of the big issues that have all the
economists in the country on edge.
You see my friend.
South Korea and especially Saul and its metropolitan area have a serious problem
with their real estate markets. A problem that has been brewing for years,
we are talking about one of the hottest,
most frenetic real estate markets in the world at the time.
[Inaudible].
No,
because I'm not just referring to the hundreds and hundreds of cranes that have
been erecting, new buildings all over the city for years. I'm also talking.
The prices over the past.
Five years alone. Housing prices in Seoul have shot up by more than 20%.
And that's on top of levels that were not exactly low to begin with.
Quite the country, meanwhile, or the same period.
Cumulative inflation has been around about six.
[Inaudible].
In other words, house prices, which were already very high,
have risen well above other prices. And that's when the problems start,
especially if we're talking about an economy that seems exhausted.
I can imagine this has made it very,
very difficult for families and young people,
especially young people to start an industry.
Light.
Skyrocketing and families need to get into astronomical debt just to get on.
Yeah.
Household debt grows much faster than anyone.
The Korea times. Well, the fact is that in the face of such a scenario,
current president moon Jae-in has this idea to make this problem.
One of his political ones.
Priorities.
During the election campaign that brought him to power.
He promised to take all necessary measures to deflate the prices of the real
estate sector and make housing affordable for young South Koreans. Now,
does this ring any bells for anyone? I'm sure it does.
It's a strategy that's trending with politicians all around, right?
[Inaudible].
And three years after coming to power things,
and South Korea are worse than ever. And yet, as we shall see,
this president has not been yet.
Procrastinate.
What exactly are these measures?
How has [inaudible] and attempted to housing affordable?
Are these measures working?
What can we learn from the changes he's made and how could this matter impact
the battered South Korean economy? When I find out.
Let's get cracking
the most inaccessible soul.
The data is devastating. You see, I don't want to bombard you with the figures,
but there are a few that are key to understanding the scale of.
The problem.
Four years ago,
buying a home in school costs roughly 8.8 years of the average full salary.
When moon became president in May, 2017,
that figure had already risen to 11 years. And at the current time,
the estimate is more than 14.
Teen years. [inaudible].
We're talking about a relatively small non luxury homes.
That is an average apartment of about 60 meters squared and a regular
neighborhood can cost almost half a million.
Billion dollars.
In other words,
the sole real estate market is almost as hot as the London market.
The difficulty in accessing housing in this setting today exceeds that of cities
like Paris, Singapore, or new.
New York.
Is not all added to this situation.
We have the slow down of the South Korean economy and the increasing
deterioration and employment figures,
something that has only been further accentuated by the coronavirus crisis.
For example,
unemployment among the youngest citizens aged 15 to 29 is close to 10% and
abnormally high level for this Asian country.
Once.
Fierce Asian dragon has stopped roaring,
and that has set off all the alarms on the one hand access to housing for young
people is becoming almost a mission impossible.
And on the other doubts are beginning to grow as to whether or not the housing
prices are sustainable. In other words,
could Seoul be facing a bubble that is about.
To burst? Yeah.
We think that's a good question because you see my friend's moon and promise to
end the hosing problems. But since he came to power,
they only been getting worse.
And worse.
Hold on. Just one moment.
The current situation in the real estate market is not money and his fault ed
has been brewing for a long time.
At least says a team of conservative presidents park when he,
who is removed from office due to a huge corruption scandal and no, well, no,
she sleeps blank.
The barns.
What did South Korean politicians do to cause housing prices in some areas of
soul to rise faster than in cities like Hong Kong or Montreal?
Well, let's take a look.
The same old root of the problem. [inaudible].
Visual quality goes.
The problem with politics is that our representatives tends to worry about the
short term about the next election,
and then not so much about what comes after that face it.
If you're a politician,
you have very little incentive to worry about what's going to happen in the
medium and long term.
That is why it is often the case that when they get their hands on institutions,
such as the central bank, things do not end well.
But that's exactly what happened in South Korea.
The combination of expansive monetary policies to encourage the grinding of
mortgages, along with the constant regulations of give and take,
and the countries,
property sector largely explained everything that has happened.
Mind you. I'm not the only one seeing this,
the former president she's telling us this, take a look at this.
I will drastically boost the property market and loosen up unnecessary
regulations so that the economy can be revitalized.
Many measures adopted to prevent property market overheating turned out to be
obstacles after the market went down. These need to be loosened up a bit.
Ex president park, June. Yeah.
Boy. Oh boy, did it all get loose?
The real estate market and Sewell is on its way to becoming the second most
inaccessible market and the world after Hong Kong,
[inaudible] take notes because when the president's full of relaxing
regulations,
she wasn't talking about rules that would limit the amount of construction or
making projects more expensive, not by a long shot.
It was basically about doping the economy by lowering interest rates and
boosting credit as if there was no tomorrow.
For example, as you can see,
there was a huge reduction in interest rates without any crisis to justify it.
The essential objective of the government was as the former president herself
acknowledges to feed the real estate sector with more and more credit.
And this way more jobs would be created. Prices and salaries would go up.
South Koreans would see their wealth grew and grew.
Interest rates would go down and young people would have all the mortgages they
needed to buy the houses they wanted and Sue everyone would be happy.
And it went even further than that.
Low rates encourage savers to invest their money beyond a typical bank deposits
to get some return
and where to families invest their money in periods when house prices are
rising, exactly the invest in more houses, which feeds the whole process.
Even more, more demand, higher asset prices, more real estate development,
more jobs, higher salaries. And let's keep this party going
because everything sounds good, right? But then the problem,
my friends is that this is precisely how bubbles are formed,
especially real estate bubbles.
Then there comes a point when prices are so high and families are so in debt
that this whole process stalls,
and then suddenly the bubble bursts until that bubble burst.
The final years of this bull race become especially hard for people who want to
buy the prices are so high and have increased so dramatically.
The Dustin's between house prices and salaries become astronomical.
And the effort to pay the mortgage is almost tight time.
[Inaudible].
And he knew exactly what she was doing.
Doping the South Korean economy to fulfill her short term promise that the
economy would grow by more than 3% a year. The problems would come later,
but that, that would be someone else's problem who cares
Brings us squarely to a key question.
How can such a colossal mess be fixed?
And I'm sure you don't need me to tell you that is a tough one.
A Saint.
Let's take a look at muni N's plan to prevent the bubble from bursting all the
while making homes more affordable. Does he have the magic formula? Wow.
Fighting intervention with more intervention.
My friends slowing down this process.
Once it picks up speeds can be as complicated as trying to stop a runaway train.
And yes, yes. Some of you might be thinking, well,
let's just raise the interest rates and that's it, right? Well, no,
it's not that simple. And it is certainly not the best strategy.
If you happen to be a politician who wants to keep your popularity rating up,
or you're thinking about the reelection of your party,
Raising interest rates are slowing down the granting of credit with simply mean
that many people would not be able to pay their mortgage or get one in the first
place. Not only that as financing becomes more expensive,
the demand for houses would fall. And this would also cause prices to fall.
And many properties developers would suddenly find their very existence in
danger. Of course,
all of this would affect more than just real estate companies.
The higher cost of financing and the Lords of money would leave many companies
of all kinds to bankruptcy.
So dozens of jobs would be lost suddenly defaults and Lundy volts with multiply
like weeds. The banking system would start to wobble, et cetera, et cetera,
et cetera.
The outcome of all this should sound very familiar to you because it's what
happens to us all in 2008,
Most likely the bubble will burst right in front of our faces.
Once you open up Pandora's box,
closing it as not so easy playing with the central bank can turn into your worst
nightmare. However size Korea is not yet quite in that situation.
And the question we can ask ourselves is,
so what does muni and want to do to avoid the nightmare? Well,
their plan was put into action on the 13th of September, 2018.
Yeah.
He presented a very ambitious package of measures measures that basically
consisted of more regulation. In other words,
trying to stop the price escalation by using the line
This week,
the government described a number of areas in the country as speculative areas,
or in other words,
areas with high demand and lots of real estate transactions in these areas,
most of which are located in soon, numerous restrictions have been put in place.
The most important of these are the prohibition of granting a mortgage to those
who already own several homes,
restricting mortgages for luxury homes that are not intended to be lifted.
And the establishment of a limit of 40% of the property price to the financing
that banks can grant to companies that buy houses and then rent them out
and this way, Mooney and seeks to limit access to credit to certain agents,
such as multiple owners and other words at once to artificially reduce demand in
order to curb the price increase. In addition to these measures,
the government also announced a public housing program to increase the supply of
real estate at pre appraised prices, listen up.
The government to supply 300,000 public homes through 2021.
The government will complete the purchase of four or five idle sites in Seoul,
in Shan and [inaudible] province plans to build four to five new,
small residential towns between Seoul and the existing large residential
areas of Elston and boondock the Korea times.
Well wait, because there's more recently,
this housing program had been extended and both the government and several
public companies have made the land available to build 132,000 new homes.
At the same time,
the maximum hate of the apartment blocks has been increased from 35 to 50
floors. And not only that,
but an urban rehabilitation program will be created to speed up the process of
tearing down older, lower rise,
apartment developments and building new higher and more efficient ones.
So basically it's a full-blown re densification project. And the end,
all these recent measures are setting Korea on a different path,
increasing supply rather than focusing on artificially restricting the month.
In fact, as you can see, despite the measures taken in that direction,
prices have continued to rise at roughly the same rate as moon's popularity,
as president has plummeted.
Moon's approval rating plummets as house prices keeps soaring Nika.
And it's kind of no wonder South Korea is facing a very complex scenario.
One hunt its economic growth has slowed down a lot. In fact, in 2020,
a slight recession is expected due to the Corona virus. On the other hand,
the housing bubble has not been stopped,
partly because the government has not only not reversed the expansive monetary
policy, but has fed it even more and an attempt to curb the economic solution
[inaudible] ends policies have undermined the country's long history of
competitiveness. This is something we talk about in this video and friends.
We could be looking at the perfect story
And keep in mind,
but this is not the first time this country has been in a similar situation.
It also happens during the late eighties and the early nineties.
Something that by the way,
ended with the country being the worst hit by the Asian financial crisis of
1997. So at this point, the questions we are left with are as follows.
How can South Korea escape from this situation is more regulation of the keys to
curbing the real estate crisis could South Korea be on the verge of a large
bubble bursting under the auspices of constant monetary interventions and
removable regulations. There are many, many questions as always.
We have visual politics. We'll be keeping an eye on what happens,
but now it's down to you.
Do you think it's justified for governments to intervene in the market?
Every time they feel the prices have risen to high, as always,
we ask the questions and we let you provide the answers.
Thanks for watching the video and as always, I'll see you next time.
[Inaudible].